BF new welcome
my name is Natalie de Rosier and I'm the
principal of Massey College it's my
great privilege to invite you here for
the science and Society Talk of the
season this is the seafar Massey talk
and it is an important occasion for us
all of us to reflect and see and think
about the great azrud of science that
are always at the front of our minds
this is the first massive talk that
we're doing in person since uh kovid so
I think I want to thank you for being
here and I also want to thank our
virtual audience we're happy to have you
with us tonight
I want to acknowledge that we are here
on indigenous lands the lands of the
young one that the miss the anishnabig
the Chippewa and the other noshoni and
it is the treaty land of the
mississaugas the credit
I want to acknowledge our duty of
stewardship toward this land as well as
our great privilege to be here together
to do this talk merci beaucoup I think
we all are so grateful that you're here
this series of talk began in 2015.
it is a series dedicated to exploring
conversations about the Nexus between
science and Society
and if anything has we've learned
anything the last two years is that
matters in in matters probably more than
ever
so it gives us here the celebration the
ability to celebrate the great career of
a cfar scientist will highlight his
accomplishment but also we'll have the
occasion to listen to him but also it's
an opportunity for us to have
intergenerational
discussions with exceptional Massey
college junior fellows who will be
respondent to the cfar scientists today
the previous lectures that focus on many
issues the future of vaccines
AI Revolution and the unresolved
Mysteries of the Galaxy just to name a
few so stay tuned for this one but also
the future ones all of our past talks
are available on the cfar's YouTube
channel and I invite you to continue to
watch them I would not want to invite
Alan Bernstein who is the cfar president
and CEO to say a few words and introduce
our speakers Alan
foreign
thank you very much Natalie and it's a
real honor and pleasure for me uh to be
here this evening uh with with my friend
and colleague Natalie De Rose the
principal of Massey and to really honor
this partnership between
cfar and Massey college and I think it
when it was first I think when Hugh
Siegel your predecessor was the was the
principal at Massey uh when Hugh and I
first discussed it it was kind of a
natural partnership because both Massey
and cfar really value
interdisciplinarity we really value
young people and that's why our Junior
fellows are going to be here this
evening and we really value knowledge
and the advancement of knowledge in all
its forms and the diversity of of people
that participate and should participate
in advancing knowledge so that was
really the basis and we also felt back
then and as Natalie just said it's
become even more important today
the issues at the intersection between
science and Society have become not less
but increasingly more important
with time and the the pandemic is a is a
case history of of that so this is a
marriage made in heaven
so
uh
so this is a a particular pleasure for
me because this will be my last
introduction of uh of a speaker at the
at the Massey events and uh so I'm very
pleased that today's speaker is my
friend and colleague Alaina spiru guzik
so I'm going to tell you a little bit
about them but I'm going to try not to
say too much because you'll be
intimidated and you'll be afraid to ask
him any tough questions so you know
please don't be intimidated so Alan um
uh was a chemist
and I'm going to read a few things put
on my reading glasses here uh he he's a
labovic fellow and see far as
bioinspired solar energy program he's a
Canada cfar AI chair his his card is a
little bit about about this wide his
business card a Canada cfar AI chair at
the vector Institute he's a Massey
senior fellow and he's a professor in
the Department of Chemistry and computer
science at the University of Toronto
where he directs the acceleration
Consortium which is building
self-driving labs and he might explain
what that means in his talk that combine
chemistry or Material Science with AI
with robotics Advanced Computing
including quantum physics to rapidly
design and Test new molecules for your
favorite application Alan has a really
interesting background and a really he's
a really eclectic thinker indeed he has
a paper out today I believe uh on what
is understanding me in in the in a when
AI is sort of being used to advance
science so to give you something to
think about
um if we can use Google Alpha fold to
predict the three-dimensional structure
of a protein
does that mean we understand how
proteins fold or does it mean that the
AI program understands how proteins fold
so I'm simplifying I know that but uh so
it's interesting to think about it maybe
we'll have a discussion about that
during
stock a land is from Mexico
he obtained his Bachelor of Science
degree for the national autonomous
University of Mexico in 1999. he was
awarded a PHD in physical chemistry from
Berkeley did a postdoc there and then
became a professor assistant and
associate and full professor at Harvard
University
and he moved to Canada
shortly after president Trump became
president now I don't know whether
there's a cut well I do know whether
there's a cause effect actually uh uh he
was one of the Mexicans that Trump was
referring to I think uh so
um it was uh our gain and America's loss
when Allen and his family decided to
move to Canada where he became initially
a Canada 150 chair to celebrate Canada's
150th birthday so he's worked on many
things he's extremely well funded by all
kinds of people and places and he's
going to talk to us today about
disruptive innovation and opportunities
in renewable energy using AI Atlanta
it's a real pleasure for me to introduce
you
[Applause]
okay
the funny story is that I don't remember
when I sent this title or if I haven't
sent this title so today I'll tell you
about AI for materials in general I'll
mention renewable energy but I won't
show you examples of it in my 20 minutes
I would just mention it
uh so thank you for the introduction
Alan and it's a pleasure to be here both
as a cfar program director of the by
spiritual energy and also some massive
help
uh I just want to always start putting
things in context
if you were to look at all the visible
universe and where to count
all the number of atoms in it just not
even Stars just atoms the number that
you get to is 10 to the 82. now you
might think okay 10 to the 82 is an
interesting number uh
well that's probably the number that we
could potentially compute if we
enumerated anything that's the largest
database we could ever have putting a
single bit in every atom of the visible
universe
so now think about all the problems that
require molecules
copy the vaccines solar cells
water filtration modules batteries keep
thinking about all the things around
those Australian dollars of our economy
but also the most important solutions
for Humanity are actually stuff
materials so if you ask yourself how
many materials can we make how many
molecules can we make can we estimate
that space
can we even enumerate them I tell you
this is a maximum number that we can
enumerate in the database
well it turns out that you had to add
100 zeros to that a hundred zeros you
think about that so you need 10 to 100
universes in each atom storing all the
possible molecules of materials that we
could make
so clearly we cannot enumerate them all
we have to actually start
thinking as a human trying to narrow
down the space of possible materials and
try to solve for a problem
so now let's talk a little bit about the
importance of Science in society
starting to talk about poop right so
this is juano one of the most important
traded resources
uh in the past Century because one
moment that you could actually fertilize
your land right so people went all the
way down to Chile and dragged that one
on boats and brought it back to other
places in the world right so that was
basically what was powering the growth
of of the number of people in the planet
so uh
turns out that people of course wanted
to to solve that problem and they
started using science
and the questions you might ask yourself
is well how does science solve this
problem in this case it's kind of like
at the border of Science and Engineering
you need to think about how to scale up
the production of something that's the
engineering side at the same time you
want to figure out what is what you're
going to be scaling up
and turns out that this is a typical
example of kind of the timeline you know
a 20 to 30 year timeline from the
beginning of the process to the end of
the process and I really like this
process because uh it's telling you what
I'm going to be telling you about
actually uh Porsche and however hired
high schools high school teachers to
actually test materials every week it
was something about 50 materials every
week we'll come back to that and they
started looking at them as catalysts
from trying to take nitrogen from air
and actually fix it into ammonia which
you can use to
to basically grow people
and how many people have watched The
Avengers do you guys remember in The
Avengers when half of the people
disappeared
well that would be the experiment if we
went back in time and we actually
removed the nitrogen fixation process
the hybrid wash process from Humanity
half of you statistically won't be here
hopefully the jerks and so on are the
ones that leave and you know we all
remain here uh but basically uh you can
see the effect of just this particular
materials Discovery in the planet
and we can keep going and on and on for
example solar cells and batteries are
perhaps two other room energy examples
that are extremely important for society
right now and membranes if you think
about another one membranes probably
super important right now that we need
to desalinate water for example
so I want to give you an example that
I've been involved with and I'm going to
use it as a case study because I'm
working also on batteries but my new new
flashy research is right now submitted
for patents so I cannot show you that
research on batteries but I'm going to
tell you about this place how many of
you have an iPhone or a Samsung cell
phone and you raise your hand all of you
have an OLED device in your head in your
hand okay so all that is an interesting
technology
Tang at Kodak I forget if it's Kodak or
one of the other photo companies came up
with this discovered the first organic
emitter in 1987 I was 10 I was 11 years
old okay and it was only until about
2007 when the first Samsung OLED phone
came out and then the iPhone came out
maybe three or four years later I forget
but before the technology was another
technology and the question is well
is it super cool to emit light from
plastic but it took about 30 years from
the discovery all the way down to uh
this company Universal Display
corporation that basically holds the
materials IP for this and sells pretty
much all the oldest materials in the
world
so why is that interesting well you know
uh
UDC there's a 77.6 billion market cap
for those of you in the Econo in economy
uh there was a strong buy suggestion I
don't know when I made this slide deck
but think about that right this is
really a new market that was created by
a new material that's just one material
okay
so why is that interesting because
around 2012 I was screening chemical
space with my computer and you know how
big it is but I was cleaning chemical
space with my computer and we were able
to find uh
three materials that were as good as
what Samsung and LG and those them had
okay
that was done in about three years of
work and we screened about a million
molecules in the computer and we that
was the first paper I used I worked on
using AI
so interesting paper eventually we
published in 2016 and that started like
this
huge idea of a lot of people starting to
use AI to search for materials
but that also gave me an idea because we
were able to screen about a million
compounds in our library computationally
we only made about 40 devices
out of them three words so there's a
huge gap of how can we make molecules
faster and test them then how much we
can compute them right so that's when we
started thinking about this idea of the
self-driving lab and that's when about
the time I met Allen actually he I was
starting in this idea and he was
supporting me making a workshop in
Mexico City to convene all the world
experts in the world this was C4 funded
to actually write a report on this topic
so I'm very thankful for Alan because I
just started to meet him and he said
sure let's go to Mexico let's make this
huge Workshop uh on the on this the
sponsorship of the United Nations and
other people and but the story of this
uh idea is well Matthias discovered is
this broken process from
conceptualization synthesis testing and
barely AI is involved so the idea of a
self-driving lab is that AI will
actually help us gather all the data as
we make and test the compounds and
hopefully by automation Drive the
experiment in such a way that I can come
in in the morning ask for a set of
experiments and come back and help with
the computer above Advanced science
faster what is our goal as a collective
of scientists that do this to try to
reduce the time to Discovery by a factor
of 10 time to scale up as a factor of 10
if possible so that if you come up with
a new material it doesn't take 30 years
or 20 years it takes you know three
years or two years
because that way we can attack the
problems related to climate change
pandemics
Etc right so let me just tell you a
little bit about self-driving labs and
let's just be a little bit historical
let me see my time because I always uh
yeah I have a lot of time so as always
uh things start very early right this is
actually 10 years before I was born I
count everything before I was born or
not so 1966 okay
Maryfield and co-authors created a
machine that synthesizes peptides
that started a revolution in biology
because now you could just use peptides
that were made by a machine this is a
chemistry advance that revolutionized
biology okay
and interestingly not many people know
actually he got the Nobel Prize for
synthesizing in a matrix in 1984. what
is interesting about this idea of
synthesizing uh materials like that is
that the biologists didn't stop the
chemists were very inspired they worked
with the biologists to synthesize DNA
and now sugars so basically now we can
make most biomolecules and why is that
because biomolecules are modular we have
20 amino acids very few building blocks
in the shoe in the sugars and also in
the DNA an RNA that means that we can
make them modularly so we the chemists
are behind and we said when we can we
make all molecules modularly and that's
the that's the mission that many
chemists and myself as well as AI
scientists and material scientists are
on
the acceleration construction that Allen
was mentioning is a huge effort here at
the University of Toronto in
collaboration with bechton Institute
CIFA and many other people
trying to make Toronto and then Canada
obviously the leaders in the world on
this idea of accelerated molecular
materials discovered
okay uh but as always one has to go back
to when I was two years old okay to to
the first paper that I have found so far
of the idea of the closed loop
which basically means
you make an experiment and the computer
and suggests the next experiment
okay turns out that an article that was
written about my research on Quebec
science the the woman that wrote that
she actually found winkov and actually
interviewed this person he was retired
somewhere in New Jersey and interviewed
him which was really cool I want to call
this person in a zoom or something but
you can see his computer program their
computer program and he was running a
PDP uh 11 computer that looks like that
so obviously since then a lot of things
have changed now we have ai we have much
better computers much better automation
and uh so let me tell you a little bit
about the 21st century I've been
studying a lot about uh okay so what is
what are the good things that one can do
as a scientist right so
what are you know I argue that if you
want to be a scientist that has impact
you want to write a technological drive
drivers of your century
where the action is happening so for
example when I was starting my career
gpus were just coming out because people
were playing with video video game video
games so we were one of the first ones
to use gpus for chemistry quantum
computers which I'm going to be asked
about I heard but you know I'm not going
to tell you about quantum computers is a
big part of my research and I go tenure
for that actually for quantum computers
in chemistry but I was working on that I
didn't realize it at the time because I
like the technological drivers and I
like to jump into them and use science
at them so I argue that some of these
things are the ones that are going to be
better for scientists because there's a
lot of technological development at the
same time another connection between
science and Society if Society is going
One Direction and developing a lot of
stuff you might as well use it for
science that's my argument
again more conceptually
is this interaction between Automation
and experiment by Control software so
what did we work on I and this is the
basically the last example in my talk
I needed to think about a problem where
the clock had just started
so we can show that we have an
automation at this acceleration I cannot
work on a material that people have
worked for 30 years and then tell you oh
I use my Ai and I
so then it was around 2017 that I
started working on this story but I have
to give you a detour how many people
know here who is Hendrick Sean
okay Hendrick Sean was the biggest
fraudster around you know when I was a
grad student he was he was extremely
famous he was at Bell labs and he
created supposedly an organic laser and
a very superconductor the best organic
semiconductor under the direction of all
these big big Bell Labs people and he
fooled everybody the Uranus the best
love stuff everybody
this book Plastic Fantastic tells you
about his fraud he's now employed by a
computer development company in Germany
I don't know I mean this guy who hires
Hendrick shark but uh at the time
chihayadachi friend of mine a fantastic
professor in Japan was a postdoc trying
to reproduce his work he says I want to
make an organic laser well he he
persisted and the first solid-state
organic laser that worked very well was
published in 2017. that's the beginning
of the clock I moved to Toronto in 2018
built a lab under the pandemic and the
lab started working in 2020. so if you
add to my clock building the
self-driving lab I'm already behind but
obviously we had a pandemic and we had
to learn how to build a self-driving lab
on the first place
but now we have a self-driving lab that
makes these complex molecules that are
basically long electron Rich molecules
that are the best emitters in the world
to make an organic laser which I haven't
explained to you what it is now in mind
instead of having an OLED think of a
knowledge that uses 10 times less power
even more times less power
as a display or that is a perfect
infrared detector
so the organic laces will mean many many
technologies that we don't even imagine
yet Plastics that generate laser so
DARPA I'm funded by DARPA another
connection between Society taking uh
military money and using it for
something good in this case so funded by
DARPA I am the pi of this project with
this five character four characters and
myself uh we call Madness because it's
really Madness we're trying to
accelerate the discovery of organic
lasers okay and without the technology
of Marty work of molecular blocks Lee
Jason and Bartos I wouldn't be able to
tell you what I'm doing so my lab
started automating and this is how they
look uh my friend Curtis Bernard likes
to say everybody likes to see videos of
robots well this is an example of a
robot in my lab wearing powders okay
that's how it looks okay so it's the
most expensive salt and pepper shaker in
the world uh it's actually really doing
that right now
and you can see here our chemical
reactors just to give you an idea how it
works now the reactor
those are all the different reactors
they are all connected to the analysis
machine in the back and to the lasers
that measure the properties of the
lasers so what makes this lab unique is
that the synthesis and characterization
and testing are all in the same roof all
controlled by AI
okay so this is how it looks the room
and I'm looking at my time yeah I have
five minutes left uh what you can see on
the right hand side is the the emission
Live lifetime measurements of those
molecules as they come out from the
robot all the way down to the HPC down
to the lasers to characterize okay so
that is a self-driving lab that's how
they look
what was super sexy is that we generated
our first library in the system lab we
run it on a weekend
and let me just tell you what this plot
is in this plot in the y-axis you see
how good the molecule is as a laser the
cross-section of emission of light by
the molecules okay so larger the number
better as a laser in the bottom axis you
see the color and the color doesn't
really matter too much but if you're
close to 450
is better because it's kind of more
close to blue and blue is a very
expensive color to make
so it turns out the best molecule by
chihaya is 1C
he spent 10 years to make it and he only
published about 10 molecules in 10 years
we in a weekend of Seth ramilla
published these 40 molecules
just a weekend I swear we sent you
higher one that we purified and it's on
the right hand side the lacing
properties of such molecule which was
one of them I forget 3C or something
there was already about two times
Battery no sorry 1.5 times better in
gain in solution and about the same time
of performance in in a device
but this was our first warm-up paper
so the rest of the you know what
happened in 2022
is that DARPA told us okay shows results
this is 2022 now we're paying you for
three years
show me the money so we created this
project called ACDC
the five Labs that I told you about are
working together across the world with a
delocalized laboratory so we make
materials in Vancouver we ship them here
they go back to Urbana-Champaign they go
to Glasgow they come back we have a
software system that actually collects
everything that's we call it AC DC it's
cloud-based delocalized right and I just
want to show you a few iterations
iteration two
I guess I deleted some slides but it
doesn't matter the green compound there
is the highest compound and the only
thing that matters here is that you can
see more dots to the top
okay so I'm just going to show you oh
sorry
we have about four iterations before we
stopped improved our chemistry and we
restarted Now new iterations and then
we're going to be done okay but my point
is that we have compounds now that are
twice as better as shahyas and we have
generated hundreds of them every
iteration that lasts a week so every
week we generate about a 500 if we want
or even 200 compounds scaling them up
and making them devices is very slow
which means now we need to think about
robots to make those devices so we just
wrote a very large Canadian Grant
application cross your fingers
to have a huge laboratory here at the
University of Toronto that is going to
have this scale up machines and all
sorts of other materials Discovery
platforms for solid-state materials to
make to be able to make batteries to
discover drugs Etc so we're really
trying to make a big initiative doing
augment the capabilities of this but
today I chose to only tell you about the
lasers but we work also on other
applications such as for example drug
delivery with my colleague Christine
Allen ah so those are my lasers that's
how they look you're seeing the
brightest molecules that exist basically
and just in my synthesizer that's how
they look okay so just two ends my last
three minutes
is this the last this is the way that
the lab is gonna look like no way
I don't know if you saw the chip in my
opinion cheap and kind of uh just uh a
little bit fake presentation of Elon
Musk of his Rod walking around like you
guys saw that
well there are companies in Canada okay
for example led by Jordan Rose there is
a company and I'm forgetting their name
in a second but it will come to me in a
second uh Sanctuary that has better
technology in my opinion a Canadian
companies has better technology than
than
um Elon Musk on this but my point is uh
we are working on the similar technology
but more realistic okay I like to take
selfies Alan and I take a lot of selfies
together this is a robot that is taking
a lot of selfies of that transparent
glassware over there
this project started about two years ago
in collaboration with animeshgar Florida
scruti and we have now about the team of
about 12 or 15 people working on this
the idea is to make the first chemical
robot that can see
and and handle
chemical glassware
in an unsupervised way the following
sense you are going to just give it the
glassware and it will figure out what to
do okay so I'm gonna this is
experimental I want to show you two
videos that we just submitted to uh to a
computer science conference
okay yeah this one should be playing and
I'm gonna switch to the next one because
this is a video that we use to explain
our paper I'm going to just show you how
it looks like you can see here the robot
is now doing multi-view right so our
road is actually looking at several
photos of the transparent glassware okay
to be able to and also we have also some
virtual uh
artificial data that we generated
to to be able to generate what we
consider is the world's best last year
we had the record and this year I think
this will also get the record of the
best computer vision system for
transparent objects in the world
okay which allows us then to enter in
the future any chemical lab and use our
AI to actually
uh C Class Square see how much liquid is
in the glassware and manipulate the
glassware and this is one part of the
project actually how we can see things
the second part of the project is how
can we manipulate it because this is my
student aruki was working a lot of the
optimization problem of making sure we
don't drop liquids right because if you
don't control the robot well you don't
have the right constraints the liquid
will be spilled so I want to show you
that is that it's not BS here is the
paper by naroki
oh is the video working yeah there it is
this is this is just recent data about a
month ago of our robot actually doing a
solubility experiment so we are learning
how to pour
uh how to actually detect if something
has dissolved or not
this is of course early days and we're
going to apply it to cocktail making
first because it's a simpler application
but you can imagine what this is going
to make to chemistry and Material
Science we're going to have this very
inexpensive robotic systems that can
enter a high school lab can enter
anybody's laboratory and then you can
automate anybody's laboratory by just
having these very inexpensive arms so
I'm going to end with that
hopefully this is my last slide yeah
this is thanking my research group for
all the work of course this is work done
by them and I think the audience for for
your time and look forward to the
discussion with the massive fellows
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you that's so exciting you know
what are you doing next weekend
so it's do you really want to know
well it's so exciting to see that the
speed at which uh things are developing
you can see that we're going to have
these talks way more often to keep on
top of the of the development so let me
invite the the junior fellows here we
have Alec Crosser who is starting as
masters of applied science in aerospace
engineering is a research will focus on
using AI to improve long-term navigation
of autonomous vehicles is from
originally from Victoria BC completed
his undergrad at University of Victoria
and what he'd like to do in the future
is to make sure that the next generation
of Canadian space exploration uses his
research or you know you'll get to be a
faster researcher after today I know
that so
Aditi Aditi mayeshari is currently
pursuing a research Masters in computer
engineering she did her undergrad in
engineering science and she majored in
robotics with an AI minor
because she is a lifelong learner she
enjoys taking part also in the social
impact design challenges that motivate
her to expand her knowledge and skill
set and her goals are to broaden our
understanding of interdisciplinary
problems so that she can go and use her
strengths for untapped development that
will advance Society and finally Alex
and Alexandra Martin is a PhD student in
the department of political science
whose research focuses on the
development of the genealogy of
explainability in the governance of AI
systems in the Euro Atlantic context
professionally she serves as a policy
analyst with the federal government's AI
intelligence Hub where she supported
citizens deliberations on AI ethics so
up to you guys you know yeah it's going
to be fun yeah
thank you very much Professor for the
Intriguing presentation as I personally
learned more about the intersection of
quantum Computing and AI for my research
I'm starting to realize that there seems
to be many views on how the research
Community thinks these two Fields will
evolve some say Quantum Computing will
be used to build faster and more capable
AI models whereas others say that AI
will be used to build more reliable
quantum computers as someone who's
worked in both these fields what are
your predictions on how Quantum
Computing and AI will evolve in the
future
okay yeah so I apologize I half of my
lab works on Quantum Computing and I
knew I could potentially be asked about
that so I didn't talk about to the
audience but
something relevant here is that just
today the chief technology officer of
sapara computing you don't go a former
lab member of mine was here he's in the
Toronto office of our company Zapata
Computing which is perhaps the largest
sole software Quantum Computing company
now that is not Google or IBM or
anything like that and we were just
having lunch talking about that
we're talking about
where do we one of the topics was where
do we see
quantum computer is doing AI right so
zapara has sapara has probably
the leadership on an area of AI
cogenerative models the models where you
generate new data Alejandro perdom
actually based here in Toronto has the
best handwritten digital generation on a
quantum computer in the world uh but we
still were asking like well is it really
going to beat
a classical computer in the near future
it will really depend on the hardware
makers right it will it will really
depend on on that kind of Technology
curve and I'm afraid it might take five
ten years I don't know exactly what's
going to be the moment I don't want to
make any prediction
when quantum computers really
commonplace or building classical
computers for certain tasks uh in the
other side AI is helping really Quantum
Computing a lot obviously AI is
embedding science
former postdoc myocrine just wrote a
paper I love his paper he shows first
that AI papers are growing exponentially
so he wrote an AI to predict which AI
papers are going to come out okay
seriously you have to read the paper
it's so interesting he looks at the
connection between the concepts and then
the concepts that are not connected with
each other Mario makes a prediction or
there should be a paper connecting these
two concepts and he published all this
data set of YouTube papers to be written
in AI predicted by an AI so definitely
the AI is impacting all science
including Quantum Computing but that's
my answer I know it's convoluted but
it's not here yet but it's happening
very quickly and it's very fun to see
the AI and Quantum just become one one
kind of thing together but don't don't
take any claims from any company out of
proportion
okay yeah okay um I'm actually going to
switch Focus just a little bit and um
I'm gonna ask that so in the field of
environmental politics um we often
discuss a particular Trend in climate
change work in particular uh known as
prometheanism so it just for
clarification it's that view that
environmental problems are challenges
that can be overcome by human Innovation
and often emphasizes quick fixes or the
pursuit of future text saviors rather
than difficult behavioral changes how do
you see your work fitting into kind of
an ecosystem of solutions and where do
you see the greatest opportunities for
AI to help Elevate Solutions being
developed in other disciplines
yeah so I always like to tell people my
opinion that uh
I do what I do because I'm a scientist
and the only thing I can do is discover
things and build machines and write
papers right and perhaps you start
companies
but
and it's a very important part of the
societal problem I am a big believer
that government
has to play a big role in this
you can just see it's out of the Border
where I left as Alan was talking about
the regulation of Environmental
Protection laws
for the water right it's so incredible
that a country's advances United States
is trying many segments of that Society
are trying to just make their legs more
polluted right just think about
that kind of moronic way of thinking so
I think you have to really think about
protecting the environment first laws
that actually allow you to transition to
a clean energy uh
fast
but Alan here is actually a big champion
of
kind of like moonshot projects where
there is also like a
you know this has to be all the asexual
Society Academia industry and the
government kind of align together to
trying to solve a moonshot and I think
if we had
Collective moonshots around say
batteries like you know solar energy
harvesting
Etc and we could make advances faster
technologically but there is a policy
side we have to actually implement it
for example Norway right what's it
what's the story of Norway I think half
of the cars already Electric in Norway
it's something incredible right this is
government top down right there are
people buying this crappy Teslas this is
what we have right now but just in mind
the Innovation if a country as large as
the United States and China is doing it
already like forces down our throats
electric cars the technological
innovation will come also they will
become cheaper and it's kind of like a
loop so I don't know how to say it but
as scientists I think our action what I
do is very limited in the sense that
um
I don't have the policy
Hammer to actually implement it right
but last thing I would say is if we
shorten the time to Discovery I do hope
that we attract The Venture Capital
money that is right now making dog
walking apps into materials apps into
materials applications right so that's
why it's so important for us to shorten
the time to Discovery so that venture
capital and all sorts of other Capital
that is now invested I think poorly can
actually help us solve more important
problems
all right so this one is a little bit
more related to your uh presentation
today so you described today your vision
for material research where Ai and
Robotics are synergistically developing
new materials autonomously
um so how do you build sort of a data
set for training
um this type of control and more
specifically how do you ensure that your
data sets that you're building are as
unbiased as possible
super good questions firstly uh the
reason we built is that the history of
the field was that
I'll tell you a personal story around
2008 or so I got an email that said
greetings from the White House that I
thought it was a scammer a scam but he
was actually real there was a workshop
in the White House about this new idea
of the Obama Administration called the
materials genome initiative
where people believe that the whole idea
and I believe that too was to generate
big databases oh we're going to generate
these huge databases and I did the
largest database of organic solar cells
in the world 3 million compounds I know
1.2 million compounds run in 300 million
calculations create incredible large
database that was useless in some sense
so people started building all these
databases of of computed data materials
data properties
Without Really realizing that the real
data is not computed it's actually
experimental so the reason I started to
move into the self-driving labs and
started working in this field so
strongly is because we like to eat our
own dog food generator we're on that on
the fly so the models that we build are
usually patient optimization models that
have a level of uncertainty associated
with every point that you actually
explore or exploit which allow you to
kind of be less biased because if you
know that a point has a big uncertainty
you want to explore more around it and
lower your bias there and so your
uncertainty and minimize bias as much
right so so we explore to try to make
sure that we go everywhere
we also exploit when we find something
good that as traditional patient
optimization algorithms work uh but to
to make the story short of course people
still use those databases but now we're
heavily complemented by experimental
data so that's the lesson that they feel
learned over the last say 15 years or 12
years that this has been going on
so we have to generate our data that's
the reason why my robots decided to
start taking selfies of the glass right
then we needed to have the first
transparent object data set so the first
paper has the data set and the algorithm
but there was no data set that made
sense for us to generate chemical stuff
so we have to generate our own data sets
yeah right
so uh during the presentation it was
really interesting to hear how you're
combining Quantum Computing chemistry
and AI for disruptive innovation in
clean energy as well as materials design
now these areas are quite multi and
interdisciplinary so could you please
talk a little bit about how
interdisciplinary teams have made an
impact on your work and like from your
experience how can researchers engage in
more interdisciplinary collaboration
okay the first thing is yeah I don't
know because of my background or my
personality we always built an
interdisciplinary lab
uh I've had people with degrees all the
way from systems biology to computer
science to engineering to chemistry
Material Science Etc in my lab right so
the people that are there I aren't as
diverse as we can and for example Mario
Grant one of the brightest people ever
have passed by my lab is now a junior
group leader in the Max Planck was
sitting in a chemistry talk
he's a Quantum Optics person
and he feared a new way of making graph
models for molecules he just by looking
and saying why are you guys not doing
what we're doing Quantum Optics
so just by having the right people in
the room is very important also
diversity matters in all certain senses
obviously uh gender diversity point of
origin diversity Etc it's also extremely
important like people really think
differently when you know coming from
different points of view so that was
also very important for my own lab
success
so now you're talking about
multi-disciplinary science uh
some of the people that I showed as my
collaborators sometimes are even seen as
as outcasts or things like that so like
some of the people that are in this
field because we struggle many fields
the traditionalists don't like some of
these people
they think that they don't know what
they're talking about or that they are
they see them a little bit as a threat
but the science is changing very fast
and
some of the people that were the biggest
attractors of some of the things that we
did in the past or we have done now are
the biggest proponents and every time
that happens I'm very happy because that
means scientists are manual but also uh
you know they're attracted to ideas and
then they work on it so uh I would say
it's extremely important to have
multi-disciplinary teams
scientists are working more and more
with each other
and yeah that's this is the future the
future I think is going to be in this
interface is between fields at least in
my vision yeah
yeah and continuing on this uh trend of
uh discussing collaboration and thinking
back to your comment on on moonshots um
I know that climate change is one of
those few topics where there's arguably
near consensus that governments should
be promoting International collaboration
on AI research and as a researcher what
have you seen as the most significant
either political regulatory or resource
barriers to that kind of international
collaboration and what do you see as
areas where Canada could better support
that type of collaborative work
okay so many things I'm gonna now talk
about cfar okay uh
as I mentioned before I I am now a new
new co-director of a program uh that his
current name is biological inspired
solar energy Fiona that is here doesn't
like the new name that we like I like
the name CO2 far for the new name okay
she thinks it's very cheesy but Allah
liked it so we have to discuss it so we
want to rename the program to CO2 far
and this is the program co-directed with
cortis burning head which brings
together people from many disciplines
back to your question
and many
backgrounds to try to really think about
holistically about the CO2 problem CO2
is the most oxidized form of carbon
so therefore it's extremely stable and
you need to destabilize it to make it
plastic or a shared or fuel or something
so how that's one of the things that we
think about okay how how can we take CO2
from the atmosphere and do something
with it but how can we emit less CO2 how
can how do the plants do it how you know
how can we maybe change the soil so that
the more CO2 stays in it and there's
also many ways that we can attack the
problem
and there's a Time skill to it that that
is a way to do this kind of focus
science project projects but now we're
talking now that I just wanted to plug
C4 but now let me jump now to the policy
uh issue
um it is very hard
so I have a lot of experience with
Mexico
they speak so I come from Mexico
originally so first of all when
administrations change you you know
everything is from at least Mexico
everything is just abandoned so we had
all this progress with the Mexicans
Allen remembers and then the government
changes and then you have to start
working with the new characters
but just last Friday there was a call
that I facilitated the Mexicans asked me
we want to make a National Battery plan
our president announced an Azure battery
plan
can you introduce us to the Canadians
that are doing that so I called Natural
Resources Canada that I know
and they took the call from the Mexicans
so they're talking together about this
right Canada help in Mexico I think
that's the way it can happen it has to
happen bottom up it has to happen
organically these things are more
disorganized than you think uh are also
lower than you think perhaps I don't
know if there's
anything that stops the Mexicans from
zooming with the Canadians and asking
them questions right so the world is
becoming closer and closer and I think
um of course if you're thinking about
the competition between China and the US
and Canada about Ai and more
geopolitical things obviously they exist
but at the bottom up there's a lot of
opportunities for collaboration I think
especially in problems like batteries or
energy
I don't know I'm very rambling but
that's what I think about that yeah
um all right so uh another sort of
quantum related question so you touched
on you touched on needing some advances
in Quantum Hardware earlier um so one of
the sort of fundamental challenges for
most of our current quantum computers is
that they need to be super cooled often
to temperatures below let below um one
Kelvin or on on that order of magnitude
and so given this sort of immense
cooling power required how foreseeable
is it that we can scale up Quantum
Computing but without having sort of
this massive environmental impact of
needing a huge sort of energy to support
this increase in computation no luckily
first of all there's quantum computers
that do not need to be cooled this have
very very well-funded company in the Bay
Area called site Quantum that has a
a Quantum Optics room temperature
quantum computer being built very
secretively by my friend Jeremy O'Brien
and I don't know too much about the
state it's very very secretive but
that's an example
um but the beautiful thing about quantum
computers is that with very few logical
qubits you can do incredible things
right because the power of the computer
is for certain applications grows very
rapidly compared to classical computers
in the amount of qubits so you might be
able to just have one single dilution
refrigerator with a chip large enough to
do a lot of damage compared to a super
computer as a matter of fact they use
very little power once called to the
point that when I visited d-wave about
10 years ago as Jordi Rose showed me a
little battery that was running their
quantum computer
literally like it's a superconductor
right so you just need to run the
control uh
the control system for a superconductor
that's really cool so yes there is power
consumption in the in the cooling but
not nothing comparable to a data center
that's not where the worry is I think
the worry is uh I participate in a
report from the uh from the
um they call it National Academy of
Sciences
on the difference between the Silicon
industry and the quantum Computing
industry
there's a huge difference that worries
me the most about quantum computers when
the chips were being manufactured there
were consumers for them for example if
you had a very small microchip it made a
radio Transit transistor radio so raise
your hand if you had resistor radios I
am old enough to have had a transistor
area right so the young people don't
even know what that is they have
maybe even say raise your hand if you
have an MP3 player they don't even know
what that is right but basically uh
those were driving the semiconductor
industry then the personal computer
in the quantum Computing world there's
not such a thing like a quantum computer
with five cubits it's not going to be
very valuable you need one that has 10
000 to a million to do a hundred logical
qubits using error correction everything
in between has to be venture capital or
federal money and it's a money pit until
that happens so that's a big difference
between classical computers that there
was a virtue circle of you know virtual
electronics and all these companies made
money while they were developing the
chips whereas now that doesn't happen so
in our report that's the biggest uh
answer the biggest answer is
the biggest problem with Quantum
Computing is the lack of that virtual
cycle in the hardware industry that when
you sell you don't have anything to sell
until you have a big enough quantum
computer
that's that was the outcome of our
report
so during your presentation you talked a
lot about Robotics and I found it really
cool that you're taking robotic Concepts
and then applying them in like new ways
for materials Discovery and you're
self-driving Labs project so what led
you towards looking at Robotics and and
taking those Concepts and applying them
to your work
because the robots that you saw in my
first part of the video were developed
in the 90s why companies like Cemex and
camspeed
they had a vision of how chemical
automation would look like
so I feel the chemical automation has to
be democratized and being very very
cheap so when I arrived here actually I
write to the vector Institute and to the
computer science department I made this
amazing young faculty member called
Florian scruti and also animation
and we started just talking about how
will a robot for chemistry would really
be scalable and so we started jotting
down all the problems and they are the
ones that are really leading This
research scientifically I am always the
fair the last author I'm just telling
them oh now let's do chemistry now let's
do cocktails or this is interesting in
chemistry but they are the real
Technologies here and I participated in
the group meetings to kind of give ideas
about chemistry but it's amazing how the
field of robotic disadvances so quickly
and I go into it because we wanted to
solve the problem of having a very very
flexible robot we had this Vision right
of I told them this vision of ah why
don't we have a robot that actually
looks at chemicals and makes them so
this has been 15 people roughly now but
maybe it started with two or three over
the last two three years and we cannot
even we haven't even put together the
vision with the planning that's our next
goal to have the system with vision and
planning all together so we can go with
natural language is working on that on
the natural language piece so you can
tell it make me a margarita
and then it will make your Margarita
based on what it sees on the table but
that will take us maybe to the spring
but you cannot imagine how many things
you need to put together to get there
but what you need really is a floating
security an image guard the undergrads
the Netherland students and the post
locks and all of us working together at
least so yeah
okay so that's actually kind of inspired
by the comment you made about the
challenges with Quantum Computing and
particularly that issue of communicating
the value of the field first versus a
comparable field that has a readily
apparent consumer element to it so on
this topic of science communication have
you found that some of the creative
approaches like thinking about the
Mixology from a cocktails perspective do
analogies like this have a role and are
useful in the way you tackle science
communication challenges or what are
some lessons that you've you've learned
from trying to especially working with
policy makers and politicians who may
have little to no technical background
how do you explain the the value out of
this work in this field
uh
that's what we pick the terms very
carefully we used to call these things
Matthias acceleration platforms then we
thought maybe self-driving lab which was
an overtime floating around was better
for communicating the idea
still not good when we're writing our
large proposal for the government we
were struggling to find if there's
something easier it was very hard for us
to explain what we do in very little
amount of time
so it's still a struggle to figure out
how to explain to people in
especially in The Tick Tock generation
how to explain to a person in a 10
seconds what you do right so I think
it's always going to be a challenge
lessons that we have learned
I was one time
also in the quantum Computing field in a
workshop at my tree where
we spent an afternoon trying to help
them write a briefing for President Bush
at the time
about entangled photons without
mentioning the word entanglement
and we were like to watch Quantum
Computing people and it's like how do we
explain entanglement without using any
technical term you guys know remember
Bush was not particularly very
I guess he now is much more smarter than
some of his predecessors but at the time
he really looked very limited right so
uh so try to explain to George Bush that
concept like entanglement was really a
fun afternoon uh and they brought this
wacko novel science fiction novel is to
try to help us
we eventually kicked him out of the room
we said you are just being so annoying
like let us think about how to show this
too so I don't know how to explain to
you like I think you just have to have
these experiences like maybe this is a
good Workshop actually this is a good
example for a class maybe we should tell
our grad students imagine George Bush or
Donald Trump needs to know what is
entanglement right right
for Donald Trump probably is a drawing
right for George Bush's maybe 10
sentences but right in 10 sentences for
his entanglement so that's the challenge
I think now how to convince politicians
I mean there are very sophisticated ones
like actually in Canada Trudeau
explained you saw this video him
explaining quantum computers right uh I
I think I think there are different
levels of politicians I've been talking
about the lower end of the Spectrum in
the higher end of the spectrum I think
it's very good uh it's easier to
communicate than with the government of
Canada so far my experience has been
very pleasant talking to the officials
here and about science I think they're
they really get it yeah
um so one thing I was kind of wondering
so building off of sort of this
optimization problem that you're working
on in the self-driving lab Paradigm how
do you sort of choose what the I guess
properties of materials that you're
looking at and how are you sort of
because you're talking about this idea
of generalizability clearly what you
currently have you know you have a very
specific setup to measure certain
properties as you're looking for you
mentioned lasers and I'm sure other
things too how do you sort of foresee
building a sort of more robust
generalizable sort of data capture side
of it as opposed to just the sort of
manipulation part of that
problem so I
I think I even got physically
sick of like exhaustion after we wrote
this proposal to the Canadian government
to do exactly what you wanted so when
you send this proposal I literally got
had to leave my work for a little while
after submitting The Proposal so what we
wrote is we want to have an entire
building full of seven of these
Laboratories it's gonna be something
like sorry six of them roughly 12 times
the size of my laboratory all gathering
this data with a seventh laboratory that
is an AI lab and software engineering
lab that just collects all the data so I
think you need to have like massive
facilities like this that are actually
exploring the chemical space faster
and crossing my fingers hopefully uh
this proposal is funded but we we
propose exactly that it's like I think
there has to be what is called a
learning curve in economics right you
have to try many things before you learn
how to do them well so we want to have
this room here where people are trying
to build self-driving Labs from many
applications and as they try to build
them they will make them cheaper better
faster scalable and collecting more data
but now you're talking about
generalizability uh
it's very hard from different materials
classes like if you're gonna go from a
solid state material to a molecule it's
very hard but within molecules you can
generalize
quite well between different application
cases
surprisingly well as you expect I can
certainly talk to you offline
but for example if you have a good model
for organic materials we'll be able to
transfer learn to many other organic
materials right so to a certain extent
right obviously but it's more so much
better than I expected it to be but
obviously between different materials
classes I have nothing to do with each
other like rubber
polymers and and hard materials then you
really need to build different models
and I think there's not going to be a
model that will ever span all materials
or all molecules
both famous last words right maybe this
will happen in 2015 I don't know
I see Alan kind of fidgeting
what a fabulous conversation
um I mean one one intervention I would
make is I think Donald Trump would
understand entanglement actually with no
problems
from from different perspectives I guess
um fourth entanglement
the
I wasn't supposed to ask for any
questions from the audience but if there
are any I would ask two things if you
could just say them what they are the
people online won't be able to hear it
so I will repeat or a land will repeat
the question oh we have a microphone too
okay thanks Jackie
and then we'll fire it either you Alan
or one of the junior fellows
and I also have a quiz for everybody
which is what is the what are the five
of us one two three four five of us all
have in common okay so any questions
from the audience
I know the answer already to your quiz
but I'm not gonna spill it yeah very
much uh I'm also Junior fellow at Massey
College I studied chemical biology in my
undergrad and something that we were
beginning to be taught
um was about green chemistry you talk
about a lot of different molecules that
you can create and about AI advancing
and transforming this world how does
your work and this work and Ai and
Automation and all this uh fit in with
green chemistry and how do you see it
advancing the world of green chemistry
in the future I love your question
because his question is about I'll
repeat it I guess it's about how this
green chemistry fit into this
so green chemistry's idea of
can we make the chemicals in the most
environmentally sustainable way with the
least waste products and sustainable
sources and so on
so I am I asked you can imagine with all
the stuff I do I must all of sorts of
things so I'm asked to be Scientific
Advisor to many startups and my answer
is usually no I'm busy I have the
startups I found it I don't have time
sorry no no
but every time I say yes every once in a
while right so one time a company by the
founder the the creator of the name
green chemistry or one of the creators
his name is Paul anastas ayale has a
company called P2 science and they asked
me can you be my science advisor
and I said yes because I want to learn
about green chemistry I don't know too
much about it so we came to science
advisor and we collaborated with them
scientifically now in understanding how
to make
replacements for silicone I don't know
if you guys know how many of you wear
makeup
raise your hand if you wear makeup how
about if you actually wear any kind of
cosmetic product raise your hand if you
have used an ecosmetic product today
most of them contain silicone
right silicone is a is made from burning
basically oxidizing sound it's very very
energy
crappy way of making this and you put it
in your face every day so replacing that
by a polymer made of citronella is what
P2 science does so one of my grad
students lost in Chang is actually
working with them on this Ai and
computational models
to try to predict the polymer
distribution such so that we can replace
the silicone in your cream by this green
effect so I think it's going to be a big
field I bought it with my feet by
helping P2 science
they pay me some money too but I many
people want to pay me money to be a
Scientific Advisor I choose the ones I
like and these guys are fantastic right
so I'm from I would recommend you to
shed sincere website and see how they
sell chemicals made this way and now
we're helping them to put AI into the
picture so that's a way to this is going
to happen I think green chemistry should
be the way we make all the chemicals in
the world
but I didn't know anything about it
until now yeah
so we have time for one more brief
question and brief answer if there are
sorry for my yeah no no it's okay
we want I mean they usually has to
answer the question twice
okay
um look uh what what a great
conversation as you guys were talking I
was thinking about
um the history of seafar and uh it's
interesting to me how much how fast and
how far science has gone since we
started 40 years ago because our very
first program
actually touches on exactly the themes
Alan was talking about which is AI
Robotics and Society was the name of our
first program wow yeah
and out of that program the program was
actually a failure in a conventional
sense
but it was a success in two ways to
import very important ways actually one
way was that uh part of it the deal with
the company that funded it was that we
would train some Engineers which we did
and that became Spar Aerospace which
became the Canada arm for the NASA
project wow and the second was there was
a young guy in that program from
Carnegie Mellon University in the United
States his name was Jeff Hinton
and the rest is history
so uh it is interesting to see uh both
how far science has come uh since uh in
the 40 years that C4 has been around but
also how much we've come almost full
circle back to our beginnings in a in a
new manifestation The Way Atlanta was
talking about in this really really
beautiful talk so I want to thank you
Elaine and our Junior fellow colleagues
Alec Alec Alexandra and uh tidy and all
of us our letters our names start with a
you know it's an interesting phenomenon
actually
for some really great questions and a
really great conversation uh with this
guy over here and I want to thank all of
you for your attention
um and uh and for showing up for today's
event our next event is uh is on a
completely different subject which also
tells you something about seafar it's on
race and research and will take place on
November the 23rd and we hope that all
of you will be able to join us that
event will bring together both the
public and the seafar community
to engage in the societal implications
of race science
please look out you'll have those some
more details on our website and we'll be
sending out some some notices a very
different topic but also one that's very
topical in the meantime I'd like to
thank everybody and invite you all to a
a tasting uh out the doors and a little
bit of liquid uh to to refresh our
throats so thank you very much and thank
to all four of you